when you sit down to write a story do
you start with a treatment or an outline
now um each each process has been a
little bit different
for me for each one
i've i've done quite a bit of um
one with treatments and outlines but
they're they're very
useful um but what i found more useful
is the
the we talked about before the movie
days that's helped me give it
give it to give it a structure but um
uh i would come with idea and then
and sometimes it depends on each each
script sometimes i'll let it flow and
just kind of
i'll have an ending and i'll have a
image
and we'll start from there but then
maybe one month later
i'll start an outline because i'm stuck
you know
so um but i like to be flexible on that
in my routine on just depending on
because some stories come out i think
it's like writing
i can only imagine if it's like writing
music some some songs you always hear
those great songs whether it's dolly
parton doing something like nine to five
in like two minutes or something like
that or like
or like someone oh i just walked into
the night and just wrote this master's
piece sometimes it pours out
sometimes it's laborious um but again
um so i you know i think those are
useful
treatments and not online so definitely
that was a great movie too yeah oh nine
to five
oh yeah yeah that's great with your film
all roads to perla
it started with an idea from seeing a
paper bag or a plastic bag
yeah well i had an image of that
i also had an image of the texas
landscape
and i had the feeling of this wide open
space
uh at night and and i knew
that one of the characters
was uh a wrestler and during when your
wrestling season i used to wrestle
sometimes you would sleep in a plastic
bag
and then i had these images of plasti uh
you know there's a plastic bag hanging
in a tree
sometimes when you drive around in the
desert and things like that
are out out there you'll see that
so it it started what with with the
landscape
seeing plastic and then having that feel
of than i thought of plastic bag body
bags
um than i thought which was
all because of day jamming you think you
start you driving your your date well i
told you not to drive and daydream but
i was on the road a lot for for my
assignments
and you're covering texas i covered
like 5 000 miles in 21 days to do like
18 shoots one time and that was how
all roads are paralyzed sort of coming
out um it's because i
saw all these places and faces and i
didn't want that to end
you know so i would just combine them
and create my own story
and were you doing a full loop around
texas the outskirts
i did i've probably i've probably seen
more of texas and texans i've been to
eagle pass brownsville
um midlands petcos
um everything for just uh
all different types of assignments so uh
and that's that that's why that
landscape
to me had so much like mystery so much
history
and and and it was just like wow this is
this is unbelievable you know it's like
you hear stories of
you know cowboys and this but to
actually
see that land it was awesome you know
and the people and and the culture uh
you can't
yeah i was definitely inspired by by
that
and then i did and then i was sent down
to houston to do
um uh a story and then that
tied in to what i was doing and in
houston there's this two mile stretch
where there are these massage parlors
illegal massage parlors and then i was
in um
i got to go on a raid with sheriff so i
would i would have all these like
interesting
heavy assignments um whether it's
immigration to that
to uh exoneree
the michael morton he was accused of
killing his wife
served uh like 22 years in
death row but later found out that he
didn't do it so
all these human interest stories i i
wanted to understand
um it you know what that was all about
we make these choices
and sometimes those choices aren't good
enough and and then we
um we have to live with the consequences
good or bad
so that's what happened in my time
driving around in texas
how did you feel let's say you get out
at a road stop
go to use the bathroom at an older gas
station or
you stop for a bite to eat at a cafe i
mean like
how was that you're just interacting
with
it's interesting being an asian american
enjoying this of going around a
different like i think i went to the
least populated county once population
like 10 or something like that
um uh
it's cool it's cool it's it's again
um i felt like i was uh
like in in in a movie all the time i
felt like it was
but it's real it's awesome it's uh the
people the culture again i keep talking
about
that um but when i would stop
it's sort of like when you get
so used to thinking what could happen
like if these laws could talk who lived
here 20 years ago 40 years ago what
what family you know it's the same thing
what happened this
stop what happened in this single
single-family home who owned it before
so your brain just goes
all over the place and i think um
working as a photographer
i was able to catch it with one frame
but now as like you you could write you
could write these stories and
just make it up you know like oh this is
what happened
fred walked out the door got hit by a
truck
his son's out for revenge there okay
now let's have fun and let's spend next
two hours writing about that
why who was who hid in the track was
there a motive what fred do that other
person you know it's
so that's that's kind of neat and that
helps with
if you daydream a lot because then you
just go oh what happens over there
well maybe fred you know had it coming
well that's what the mayor said well the
sheriff is about to you know just
so good you can keep going it's it's
fascinating
interesting on being on the road you you
i think we're where we behave
differently too if for let's say i took
a greyhound
across country one time as a kid and you
if you're in your own car versus
you're in you know waiting in line at an
airport or something
and you just you're seeing all these
people and you're imagining what their
lives are like and they're looking at
you thinking the same thing
you know and it's just i don't know
we're just in a different mindset i
think when we travel
even just domestically you know so
anyway
yeah when you're seeing like you know i
would walk
when i was in new york or anywhere even
here
and you walk by so many people and
you're just like i wonder
i wonder what their are we ever going to
meet again
then you're like i wonder how many
photos i'm in
in the background that you know that i
don't know
of and things like that and you then you
realize
how many people are in this world and
then you realize
how many um stories there are
but then you're like we're all human we
have these same emotions
how do we tap on into that and that's
why when you hear
music and songs that could move
a whole country a whole world that is
amazing to have
write something in three minutes to have
something play in three minutes
and it just moves everyone um
yeah mozart or anything like that elvis
elvis
and and and beatles so
which means we're connected in a certain
way we're connected with emotions
um so i think when we travel
though we see different things different
lands different people
who are still connected with those human
emotions and things you know that's
that's what the fun part is as a creator
so um i grew up
um and if uh from i'm from laos my
grandmother
um came to the states in 1986 she didn't
know any english
so and my allow is
not great the greatest so it's for us to
communicate
was there's other other ways maybe
that's why i like
filmmaking or photography it was other
ways to communicate there's
were like she would i would try to have
to translate general hospital
to her and why luke and laura got
married and things like that
in lao and it was funny so when you when
you
with another language and you got to
find other ways to communicate maybe
that i got
so into visuals into into sounds
so those are things that could express
things versus
literally i am sad you know i'm telling
you i'm sad versus like
uh a frown you know so that kind of
stuff so
it's it's it's neat
you